have you ever seen someone at work get
falsely accused of essay yes let me tell
you something very quickly on that
so sorry I briefed into the camera
um at my at my at my last my last job
when I was an employee
um
so
there was there was like a weird
um situation going on where if if anyone
told if anyone knows me I I just I told
the truth like that's that's what I'm
that's what I'm known for yeah that's
what my channel is about 100 interviews
go and check that out on YouTube
um so basically
it does offend people sometimes you know
some you know people want to hear nice
things but unfortunately I wish I could
you know the truth was always nice but
it's it's not I'm just the messenger I'm
just gonna tell you what it is but
unfortunately sometimes it's gonna make
people uncomfortable so this was
happening at work and the HR lady
um did not uh love the fact that I was
doing this and highlighting certain
things so she tried to put me under
something called the performance review
um and started trying to like follow me
like outside of work I just I turn I
turn and see uh certain places like all
of a sudden she's on my same tube into
work and weird little things that I
thought I kind of fought nothing of and
then
um one day she called me into a meeting
it was just me and her in the room
and I was she she said to me
um she said she said something about
black people yeah
um which I know is not the topic but
immediately in that moment I resigned I
had to I resigned the job
um and but the way I did it the way I
did it because it's just me and this
lady in the room I'm a big black guy
I very very carefully said to her with a
smile on my face I would like to resign
it's not you yeah it's not you it's it's
all good
um but I've been thinking about it for a
while
um I've already written a letter I
hadn't
um I'll say I'll send it to you later on
I just I'd like to resign I think I'm
ready to move on with a smile
walked out the room and then went and
made sure I was somewhere where everyone
could see me and started to explain to
one or two of my colleagues what
happened uh and then shortly after that
I moved on because I know that if I had
not
um for some reason I felt like if I
hadn't handled that situation in that
way that woman could have come out of
that room and said anything
about me doing essay or anything to her
in that room and
you know I I'm not aware though not that
I look like a weirdo or nothing but you
know it's not hard for someone to say oh
look at this poor
um
um you know little white woman and this
big black guy and it's it's believable
if someone says something about like
about me
um something about me like that it's
believable look at the size of me you
know what I'm saying so I had to handle
that situation very carefully and use my
wits
um so yeah I just wanted to tell that
that story very quickly on that point
ever did she accuse you of something or
no no no no she she couldn't because the
way I did it okay yeah the way I did it
she couldn't there was no cameras in
that room but the way I kind of smiled
and
you know made her just made her
comfortable and then but Alex yeah what
was the Assumption what was the
assumption that she could say that about
you he was safeguarding it's like so
form of safeguarded do you know do you
know what it is yeah I'm I've just see
I've seen enough situations
what have you seen enough situations
like that where people
so I learned from other people's
mistakes and it's and it's not a
person's mistake sorry but it's not a
person's mistake to not look out for the
lie that's coming against them but it's
it's still I learned from that situation
and decided exactly how I was gonna
handle you know that situation at that
time when they're spiteful I've heard
guys talk about how they were accused of
essay after they rejected a girl and
like there is there's one case in the
U.S where a girl accused a guy of sa and
um they they kicked him out of the
school even after footage came out of
her pulling him in to kiss her at the
bar her pulling him back to the dorm and
like clearly like flirting with him all
over him all night and then
like he still got kicked out of the
school even with all that evidence and
footage that came forward that's the
problem like it's easier for women to
play that card than it is for men like
men don't have any sort of backup on
that topic and that happens every day so
what he's saying like I completely
understand
what about you China yeah so I know so
many um I could give you examples of
this but what up so
it's you know what I'll say remember the
story that I told you I'm not going to
speak about that but I'm actually um I'm
actually writing a play about something
something about this we're going to put
it on next year so when it yeah as we
get through I'll let people know but
there's actually a story that I'm
writing about it's quite it's quite
poignant and so I'm putting it I'm going
to put on them
on on a theater production of it next
year uh so but what I will talk about
we'll talk about a friend of mine's case
I'm not going to speak too much about
him because I don't want to let it go
but what I will say is a friend of mine
was working he had a very good job
um in the educational sector
um
he was uh there was a new role that's
about to come out he there was a
colleague of him like they used to have
a bit of Bounce but it was nothing you
know I'm trying to say to you he went
for a job role she went for a job role
he was given the job role she was not
given a job role everything was fine I
put to that point after that point he
was given the job role he obviously
became her boss and then now he had to
get to do certain things and you know
what I mean so she didn't like the fact
that he was given the job role and he
was now her boss even though they were
fine 100 before everything was fine she
started creating problems within it and
saying that she can't work with him and
then obviously the um hatred was like
why can't you work with him and then she
came around he's been inappropriate and
that created a whole spiral of events
that happened and when I know how hard
my boys come from nothing it's not one
of the it's one of these people that's
come from nothing like war-torn country
to climb up and to get yourself go to
university get yourself an educational
sector and he was like the only black
person in there and then she was also
um she was a black girl mix so it's got
and then those are two of them and when
she went and made whatever allegations
against him it set a whole spell of
events that put him through and I had to
witness this man go through this pain
like and he's my friend and I was just
like why is she doing this but she just
didn't like the fact he got the job and
she didn't get the job
um
in the end he had to go on some HR
course about inappropriate conduct at
work he he kept his job and everything
was fine but you see after that he um he
left he left the post and went somewhere
he was just like bro it wasn't the same
he was like I didn't want to climb up
any higher in that industry even though
that they and they found me it was not
guilt but everything was fine just the
fact that he had to be put through that
that whole process so you see what he's
saying Alex he's saying I
see as a man
and when you put yourself in a scenario
that's why I said don't move to girls I
don't because I could never have a woman
say to me that I came and approached the
inappropriate because I don't even do it
so I'm saying to she's gonna have to
approach to me when you see the messages
between us two it's not going to be me
that's trying to say it's going to be
her because we live in a new world now
and I've always been like this but ever
since women have said oh you know what
if a man's walking down the road I
expect him to cross over this over the
road because it makes me feel nervous
I'm I'm minding my business you know I
got my hoodie on I'm I'm doing my own
thing but now
what women are these okay okay you're
saying what women are these I'm just
saying no but the same women that are
talking about the rubber necking or cat
these that's nice I mean I've seen women
that would be myself are you referring
to myself no so you asked me a phantom
you asked me a question and I'm speaking
so you're saying which women are doing
this you talked about the advert right
the same women that are talking about
the advert are the same women that are
making a man cross over the road because
personally I would never I didn't say
you I didn't say you see what we're
doing is you're making about you stop
making it about trying not to have it
but you're making it about you I'll give
you an example that definition of sexual
assault and it says for example pressure
there we go so manipulation bullying
intimidation threats deception drugs or
alcohol they're trying to include if a
guy this is the stupidest should have
ever heard of my life if a guy lies to a
girl about his job and she sleeps with
him like thinking he has that job
they're going to say that's essay
I understand I understand where they got
it from in terms of
if obviously you know I mean like that's
the level of manipulation if someone did
something obviously it's not good but if
someone slept with somebody based on
what they thought they worked as and
then they found that they didn't it's
like I want to call it essay though I
call that an owl no the person
I wouldn't call the SAE by passing me
but I understand where they tried to put
into the category yeah it's a form of
manipulation but that's not sexual
assault though so what it is is like the
sexual assault comes from if you've told
me you don't if you know that you're
gonna tell me you're a bin man so I
don't care let's give a real like if
someone was to say Ben man oh you just
did something yeah I mean Council work
or whatever it is I don't care
personally I'm not discriminative or
prejudice against anyone on their work
but like if you told me that's what you
did I would take you as that and I'll
take you from that but if you've had to
lie to me to tell me that you do
something else for me to take because
this is not you you're on the bus stop
in my vagina trust me
you see where the men are coming from
it's like like if a guy tries to
convince you to sleep with him that can
be seen as coerce that's creepy
right I I understand like okay like I've
seen I I think every girl has had an
experience with a guy that's like too
pushy right but there's a difference
between pushy and sexual assault yeah
and I just think recently in recent
years we've been blurring the lines to
the point it's confusing confusing and
men like China are like you know what
screw this every girl's different every
girl is gonna one girls one girl's gonna
report me one girl's not one girl's
gonna think this is flirting one girl's
gonna report me for assault that they're
just like you know what [ __ ] this I
don't even want to deal with it and
that's why men don't it's fine for you
not me I'm like I want to be a girl stop
with these I'm like foreign
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible